ces images sont celles d'un drame qui a
bouleversé la france il ya 17 ans et
pourtant les français de l'époque ne les
ont jamais vu entre elles et eux il y
avait la guerre c'était en 1942 le 9
février à 14h30 dans le port de new york
normandie sombre et au milieu des
flammes
par delà les milliers de kilomètres qui
nous séparent et de lui la nuée
rougeoyantes qui le dévorait répondait
comme un écho sinistre à la nuit de
l'occupation
dix sept ans plus tard au large d'une
île japonaise pour les besoins d'un film
une caméra qui probablement n'avait pas
de coeur fait jouer à son tour à
l'ile-de-france son dernier rôle celui
de sa propre mort
la fiction dévorer la réalité
et fo dans ce faux naufrage pour des
centaines de figurants sauf pour 1 seule
l'ile-de-france lui même
[Musique]
duy sur les chantiers de penhoët un
nouveau transatlantique français
s'apprête à prendre la relève
c'est le france il a gardé un peu du nom
de l'île de france et beaucoup de la
silhouette du normandie pour les
ouvriers qu'ils construisent chaque
minute compte 300 passagers ont déjà
retenu leurs cabines au bureau de la
transatlantique pour son premier voyage
qui aura lieu sans doute en 1960 cette
tôle river à beaucoup d'autres mettra
cinq jours pour relier le havre new york
mais il faudra encore beaucoup de jours
et de nuits de travail ininterrompu
avant que la coque de 300 mètres
n'abrite les luxueuses cabine climatisée
que vous rêvez peut-être déjà l'habiter
comme l'un des 2000 passagers sept
longueurs de 315 mètres et est calculé
pour que le france puisse franchir sans
engage trois crête d'un seul coup 8
chaudière assureront offrant une vitesse
supérieure à celle du normandie qui
avait trente deux chaudières
il sera dit on une stabilité totale
et c'est par ces fenêtres qui
ressemblent à des écrans télévision que
vous verrez peut-être un jour prochain
défilé comme un angle en panoramique le
port du new york le jour maintenant à
ses proches ou cette carcasse de faire
encore piqué par la rouille ressemblera
à ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]